Okay.
So
now there's an idea that's,
that's reflected in the Jacob's ladder story,
that the center where you put the pillar is also the place where heaven and
earth touch.
And so that's,
that's a complicated idea I think that you can,
you know,
I'm trying to look at these stories from a psychological perspective.
And so then you could say that that's a symbolic place where the lowest and the
highest come together.
And so it's a place where earthly being stretches up to the highest possible
ethical abstraction.
And that's the center because one of the things that defines us say,
as opposed to them,
is that we're all United within a certain ethic.
That's what makes us the same.
This is a complicated line of reasoning,
but
I'll go back to it after I show you some more pictures.
But,
so that's,
that's the first idea is that the center is the place where the lowest and the
highest touch simultaneously.
And so you could say that in some sense it specifies the aim of a group of
people.
That's another way.
You know,
if you get together with people to make a group,
even at work,
you group yourself around a project and that unites you and it unites you
because you all have the same aim.
You're all pointing to the same thing.
And that makes you the same in some ways.
Because if you're after the same thing I am,
then the same things are going to be important to you that are important to me.
And the same things,
they're going to be negative to you that are negative to me because our emotions
work out that way.
And that means I can instantly predict you,
I know how you're going to behave.
And so our aim,
which is basically our ethical aim,
it's because we're aiming at something better.
At least in principle,
we're aiming at something better.
It's our ethical aim that unites our perceptions.
And that's what aligns or emotions.
And so that sort of begs the question,
if you're going to build a community around what aim should the community
congregate?
Okay.
So the idea here is that the coe,
the center of the community is the pillar that Unites Heaven and earth.
So it unites the lowest with the highest.
So there's some intimation of the idea that it's the highest that unites the
community.
Okay.
And so keep that in mind.
And that's a very old idea as well.
That's the idea of the access Monday,
which is the center pole that unites having an earth.
It's an unbelievably old idea.
Tens of thousands of years old.
It might even stretch back to whatever our archaic memories,
Quasi Memories,
I dunno how what you would describe them archetipal memories of are excessively
old ancestry and trees.
When the tree itself was in fact the center of the world and that it was ringed
by snakes and chaos.
And so while we have no idea how old these ideas are,
but they're very,
very old and evolution is a conservative business.
Once it builds a gadget,
then it builds new things on top of that gadgets like a medieval town.
The center of the town is really old and new,
newer areas of the town get built around it.
But the center is still really old.
And that's what we're like,
you know,
our,
our platforms like our,
our basic physiological structure,
this,
this skeletal body is some tens of millions of years old or older than that.
If you think about vertebrates,
it's much older than that.
And that's all conserved.
So everything's built on top of everything else.
All right,
so there,
there's a kind of a classic town and there's the idea,
I showed you this,
this Scandinavian world tree,
same idea at Unites Heaven and earth and around the roots of that tree are
snakes that eat this tree constantly.
So that's the idea that there's stability,
but there's constant transformation around that stability.
And at the same time,
the snakes are knowing in the roots there's streams that are nourishing it.
So it's sort of,
it's sort of an echo of the idea that life depends on death and renewal
constantly because your cells are dying and being renewed constantly.
Right?
If they are just proliferating,
then you have cancer.
If they're just dying,
then you dye it.
You have to get the balance between death and life.
Exactly right.
So that you can actually live,
which is also a very strange thing.
So,
and that tree is something that reaches from the bottom layers of being maybe
the microcosm all the way to the macrocosm.
That's the idea.
Anyways,
so then there's,
okay,
so there's,
there's uh,
Jacob and his and his pillar.
He's got this idea that you can mark the center with this stone.
Like it's sort of symbolizes what he was laying on when he dreamt,
but now he's got this idea,
you put something erect and it marks the center and it symbolizes his vision of
the highest good,
something like that and the promise that's being made to him.
And then this is an Egyptian obelisk,
the pyramid on top of it.
Um,
that's in Paris.
It was taken from Luxor and it put in Paris.
And so that's a much more sophisticated
instance of the same idea.
Okay.
And there was a stone age cultures across Eurasia that put up these huge
obelisks everywhere.
These huge,
like the Stonehenge is a good example of that.
Although it's,
it's very sophisticated and there are also markers of places.
We don't know exactly what their function is,
but they're very much akin to this some permanent marker of place.